st
der mensch ist jetzt wieder das macht
sie glücklich
drücken sie jetzt aus hochstadt und bin
wirklich verbrannt und im internet um in
die haut kammachi um das größte und
natürlich sporty mailbox nicht
unglücklich nein damit wenn ich
möglichst
was wenn man wenig habt aber
ausgerechnet da lebt wo die meisten so
viel haben wie sonst nirgendwo
davon handelt dieser film
zürich ist die stadt mit der höchsten
lebensqualität im ganzen land und dieses
land gilt als das glücklichste der welt
hohe lebenserwartung hohes einkommen
gute bildung und eine stabile politik
lassen uns in einem eigentlichen
paradies leben doch paradiese pflegen
seit jeher die un- art dass sie ihre
bewohner in missliche situationen
bringen können
rt
bz
der mann der hier am bellevue in zürich
alle so freundlich grüßt ist hans peter
maier auch er lebte einst wie im
paradies
meyer betreute als it-spezialist
börsenhandel software für banken
er verdiente gut und arbeitete viel doch
dann verlor er den job in einer für die
rote des vermieters obama verliert
allmählich bezirk dort im prüf davon ab
elektronik nun soll es mehr und dann ist
einfach so passiert davon vereint auch
ein anderer soll eigentlich wohne wo
nicht es ist ein unfall geschieht wird
vermutungen und das ist ein sehr schwer
verschiedene faktoren zusammenkommen das
gesicht dennoch erfahrungen weil meyer
laptop und firmen handy mitsamt allen
adressen abgeben musste stand er von
einem tag auf den anderen allein da 26
jahre lang hatte er sich alles leisten
können
der alkohol tat das seine dazu dass er
sich mit knapp 50 jahren plötzlich
eingestehen musste in die armut
geschlittert zu sein
dafür wird die stadt zum arm so
allgemein bin ich sagen es ist
wahrscheinlich 127 filme verständnis
dafür
außerdem natürlich enorme stützen der
enorme länder viel zufrieden mit dem was
sie eigentlich können
im gegensatz zu hans peter mayer hat nur
die kälin gar nie viel besessen sein
vater hatte sich das leben genommen als
er noch ein teenager war
und so war es früh an rudi mit einfachen
jobs die familie durchzubringen
mal als fensterputzer mal als
zeitungsverträger mal am skilift
irgendwann zog es ihn von davos weg nach
zürich
wieso sind sie obdachlos wurden ich bin
da zu machen steht als zehn euro
52 peter konrad arbeitet ebenfalls als
verkäufer des straßenmagazins seit ende
der 90er jahre hilft der verein für
brice menschen in sozialen
schwierigkeiten dabei sich aus eigener
kraft von abhängigkeiten zu befreien
mehr tolle pro häftling und für sachsen
mit 20 13
zu einem großen teil finanziert sich der
verein über den verkauf des
straßenmagazins dazu kommen spenden und
fördergelder zypries erhält keine
staatliche unterstützung
auch für peter conrad sind die hefte
eine wichtige einnahmequelle in guten
monaten macht er bis zu 2000 franken
trinkgeld mit eingerechnet
nicht wenig für einen der vor ein paar
jahren ganz unten start
wir definieren sie armut ganz verhalten
also an bord der ältere der satz an bord
hallo zeigen wo nutzer kann mit ihm
eigene krankenkasse und jetzt nötig
deegener kofinanziert das ist eigentlich
definition armut wobei ich werde mein
armut betroffene eigentlich nicht als
arm bezeichnen will daraufhin fiel
riechen sie werde mein antrieb zum
beispiel kameradschaft oder
kollegenschaft ich mir da mal wichtig
werden galt also sie sind nicht ich bin
rieche person neben dem verkauf des
straßenmagazins haben conrad und kelly
noch ein zweites standbein den sozialen
stadtrundgang seit 2014 führen sie
interessierte gruppen durch zürich und
zeigen ihnen heute die wie sie selbst
ein wenig abseits stehen rundgang nummer
2 beginnt am zürcher hauptbahnhof
zehn jahre später also kein problem also
ich möchte allen acht herzlich begrüßt
diesen sozialstaat punkt kann er endlich
was ich studiere die nicht mit peter
also ich bin in sahne geboren
phase 2 küster eigentlich nachzügler
betriebsunfalls sie die nummer planen
sie aber trotzdem schön ich in 3 k sein
werdegang führte nach erfolgreicher
kochlehre in etappen abwärts erst lehnte
er einen vermeintlichen freund mehrere
zehntausend franken aus dann verunfallte
er ohne taggeld versicherung und zuletzt
wurde ihm gekündigt 20
geboren in basel ii nach drei wochen in
batterien nach bleibt nach wenig auf der
rolshover die besucher des rundgangs
erfahren zum beispiel das zum
hauptbahnhof zürich auch eine kleine
kirche im untergeschoss gehört
bahnhofs viele symbolisch zeigen die
kuppen kieler team vor der bahnhofs
kritisiert eigentlich zu viele spins und
paulus kita bietet eigentlich zwei jahre
geboten
der raum der stille das ist quasi jedes
kapelle doch jeder nina der hauptbahnhof
bietet mit der bahnhofs hilfe einen
weiteren dienst an von dem die meisten
reisenden gar nichts wissen so genannt
die übergabe stellen sinken
tritt und mit der bahnhof stimmabgabe
sachsen wieder verschwindet
im trio mit besuchen
umgekehrt
das ist der fall wo einfach geld unser
verstand
okay das ist schön
grüne mit
der wollte bloß damit keine grenzen die
obdachlos sind
alkoholprobleme drogenproblem land wie
viele beamte und wenn shell den
stationen einer ganz starken parasiten
dem fußbruch die derzeitige wo trotz der
mensch halt ich besser schlafen muss ich
gar nicht wenn die helfer zwischen
mützenich sind ihr aber stolz ich bin
auch ein landeplatz und das ioc die im
nächsten monat die wette
im reichsten land der welt leben sieben
bis acht prozent aller leute an oder
unter der armutsgrenze randständige
arbeitslose obdachlose oder auch
menschen die trotz arbeit die
grundbedürfnisse ihres alltags nicht
finanzieren können
c
wir freuen uns darauf der andere
versucht den staat das sind keine
wohnung merkt ja am anfang ist es
natürlich dann sehr schwierig und mit
der situation aber ein weiterer besuch
und das man dass man sie in thailand zur
traurigkeit und sieht einfach nur noch
zu projizieren
also der selben sache nie gestoßen ja
das vierte foul war mit 18 punkten nicht
vorwärts peter meyer erkannte dass es
nur einen weg zurück gab nämlich den
ohne alkohol
er schaffte es davon wegzukommen und
nahm sein leben neu in die hand
die situation im moment im kreis güstrow
niveau und das finanzierte fonds von c
also startete wir patientin funktion und
betrieb der ein viertel weniger
verkäufer wird durch den ganzen zu und
rolfes bestritt ich glaube dass ich
spielen
stock sind es wichtig das ist mir sehr
wichtig jedes jahr besuchen vier
millionen menschen aus aller welt die
stadt mit ihren sehenswürdigkeiten
sie schlendern oft nur wenige meter an
sozialen einrichtungen vorbei ohne von
ihnen notiz zu nehmen gassenküche
notschlafstellen ambulatorien für
menschen am rande der gesellschaft sind
genau diese einrichtungen oft die
einzige möglichkeit wieder fuß in einem
strukturierten alltag zu fassen warum
wir eigentlich die stadt für sie ich
habe ein mitglied umso mehr umso besser
nach einer wette aus zürich und der
dritte grund ist eine von nur der
hauptpunkte mythischen sagen schön in
einer wenig nämlich dass es kölner dafür
will sich bitte ihre mikro ständig was
über 22 verdiente werk das betriebsamt
ich werde an schulden abzahlen vom
umfang her und das sind meine schulter
für die musik oder wollte grad stark und
ganzen ist es eigentlich von dem verein
würdig führt das sind die
verschiedensten derzeit also kreuz und
quer durch seine schicht eigentlich
liegt wollte ein verein mit schaffen und
dirk timmermann die gestik und kritik
über gratis nachkochen dabei jedoch
eigentlich mehr seit allerdings etwas
mit nötig
essen überhaupt will aber nur einmal bin
ich zwei minuten da geschehen thüringer
allen jugend regelmäßig also kann man
ohne probleme und ist nur haft
in zusammenarbeit mit über 20 sozialen
einrichtungen bietet der rundgang
täglich verschiedene touren an
die sechs stadtführer erzählen dabei aus
ihrem leben und helfen mit vorurteile
abzubauen
auf der heutigen tour sind auch zwei
verantwortliche des vereins ölpreis mit
der gruppe unterwegs
das sind überlegen sie zum der
stadtrundgang zuerst in basel nicht auch
in syrien überhaupt initiieren
unsere service verkaufen sind eigentlich
so die gesichter der armut als erstes
verkauft lebt ist meistens an uns
betroffen
es ging noch einen schritt weiter zu
gehen die armut auch hörbar spürbar
sichtbarer zu machen
und deswegen haben uns entschieden die
armut auch im rundgang darzustellen und
zwar wirklich die armut betroffenen also
direkt darauf betroffenen auszubilden
dass sie kompetent über armut auch
erzählen können dass ganz wichtiger teil
für sein projekt das mir dass wir auf
eine ebene bringen was netzwerk schau
gestellt wird so dass es mir sie eine
expertenrunde in england oder in
ermöglichen und das erhoffen wir uns
dass man vor dem zur schau stellen und
sie sind diana opfer oder weg und wir
sichern sich erklären sich eine
begründen und erzählen was passiert ist
und dass sich authentisch zürich habe
lernen müssen mit der armut umzugehen
inzwischen gehören die straßenverkäufer
in ihren roten jacken zum stadtbild sind
obdachlos
es war ja und den wahnsinn treibt ich
habe geklappt größtenteils will mit
kündigte lediglich an hohen kapazität
zum obdachlos sie ja wenn ich dort
zurück nach los
daniel stutz ging einst ins gymnasium
der sehr intelligente junge mann kam
jedoch mit dem leistungsdruck nicht klar
und brach die schule ab
den wunsch paläontologe zu werden
verschob er auf später und verdiente mit
gelegenheitsjobs viel geld zu viel geld
vielleicht dass er zuerst mit drogen
dann mit der spielsucht bald wieder
loswurde
es folgten drogensumpf und
obdachlosigkeit zu wenig ist als finder
vor augen halten
und ja das ist der hauptverdiener das
schwert um das rede natur ist das also
ursprünglich ist mir sehr schwer
gefallen als er lang mehr oder weniger
kein kaltes gange
aber die steuerung 160 pixel dar und ist
dass wir sicher zu fahren damit ebenso
offen lebensgeschichte ausrede in grund
überraschend gute erfahrungen
es ist erstaunlich wie viele tasten
positiv reagiere da wie viel man das
eigentliche geschichte hält die stadt in
bezug auf drogen geben wollte sie misst
und versteckte eigentliche sache
also hier fühlt sie mehr zahlen so
genannte wochen sichtlich ein
schlafplatz von motto trotzdem seien
geborgen
bis 30
also egal zu unbedingten frühere herab
sich jetzt das ist der schule bezahlt
und jetzt eine halbwegs bin ja krank
politiker die country schlafplatz im
sommer platz einen reitplatz und winter
blood drive platz im teo 6000 8000 euro
wird ein kredit sucht das ist sicher
polizei aber nicht durcheinander
hochwasser geschützt im sommer und wenn
ich mit gästen zählen nicht jetzt
mittagessen signal wieder raus fast
nostalgisch erzählt wurde kälin wie er
früher im sommer jeweils unter freiem
himmel lebte für mich ist es nicht eher
so gewesen so wahrscheinlich wie gar
nicht im seco schlag die mediale zwei
tagen die luft und machen sie mögen
natürlich mögen jetzt einige einwände
hätten doch alle gerne mehr und
freiwillig habe noch nie jemand auf
reichtum verzichtet das hieße aber auch
den abschließenden worten dieser männer
keinen glauben zu schenken
was führen sie hüpfen viel besser das
labor fatales ist leider ja mitleid mit
deiner altlasten sehr vieles ab sondern
muss härter arbeiten mit dem ganzen
handelt großer vorsicht mittlerweile
viele filters und zufriedener schlappen
als damals obwohl jetzt natürlich viel
weniger teil zu verfügung
natürlich also schätze frühjahr mit
machten natürlich nur machen aber
allgemein und ist eigentlich viel mehr
tat als sehr unsicher sei denn man alle
schuld sind wirklich zwei wochen fähre
will ich bin schon mal zwei ernten
amerika xii und das hat mir so gut
gefallen dass der nokia wieder
verwirklichen
das bild ähnlich leid dass ich nicht als
bürgerlich ich habe daheim zu jahr sogar
nieder jetzt alles war die wohl aus 15
jahren
kritik an dem plan im prinzip jetzt
alles noch ins nachrichten
und meldet wies methodik und nacht ich
lattenkracher von müttern und söhnen
ganz schön ins plus